are you kidding me we're gonna draw a
better tune in than the U.S England
World Cup I don't know it's zero zero in
the 80th minute
we're live yep
we're live
how we doing
we're uh you'll notice
that in the bottom left-hand corner it
says garyvee but he's not here yet
he should be walking the door any second
in the meantime
me and Nate holding down as hosts
Happy Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving to
everyone
thanks for joining with uh 10 minutes
left to go in the England USA game
are we still zero zero still zero zero
we can do a little play-by-play before
Gary gets here it's gonna say call the
call the football match before uh John
is in the old Wine Library office
um John and Gary were doing a bottle
signing there today
well John wasn't signing yeah a couple
big empathy drops today between uh rare
robot and empathy sparkling wine
it's available at Wine Library currently
all right for everyone just tuning in we
should be
uh should be diving into this in just a
few minutes we're just waiting on Gary
should be on any second now
be back
much better looking isn't that right
looks different but he looks great
so fun fun fact about the office trout
he's in uh
I've told the story before but I
interned at Wine Library with Gary
that's the first time that I met him in
2009
um and I interned at Wine Library in New
Jersey where John is right now and I
worked out of that office where Brandon
used to work so I went into the office
every day sat next to Brandon did a
bunch of random intern work in 2009 so I
recognized that office
very much so
few more grays in the beard now Nate a
lot more grace than the beard
was a young
young kid at that time
still look great though
someday some days
who um I'm curious how many people have
tuned in and actually
bought the rare robot it's available now
right the site's live links are up we're
at robots live uh pretty limited
production on this one too the smallest
so far right far away smallest so far uh
only about 250 cases or so I know we've
had some sales so far but pretty pretty
limited production for this Black Friday
offer
yeah
I saw some early uh full case buys come
through from some people too so I feel
like
this could go quick
Dustin can we see all the comments as
they come in or some of them not show uh
shall we
[Music]
um
you should have to see everything
LinkedIn Facebook YouTube and Twitter
got it
still zero zero in the game
it's a nail biter yeah can we get some
action from some people throw a couple
comments up there I just feel like we
haven't
wanna make sure this is uh working and
coming through
there we go there we go
do we ship outside of the states not
unfortunately there's a
something we've
made how long have we been working on
that now three years trying to figure
out yeah it's been a little while we're
working on it though hopefully getting
to International at some point
in 2023. I feel like we said that every
year but there's a path to get there but
um
it's a more complicated than one would
think with uh
alcohol yeah
Marielle you were just here so were you
picking are you going pick up of the
sparkling wine and then
scooping the rare robot
seems like the right play yeah
it's a good Black Friday
do we want to talk about um the
sparkling just for like a second before
we get into the rare robot with Gary
yeah you had it yesterday right
I did I got a couple bottles um
so we made a again limited production
but we made a sparkling uh brute and a
sparkling rose and have a
exclusive kind of deal with um go puff
to distribute through go puff in their
distribution centers and not every state
in the U.S but I think it's about like
20 25 States so if you log into gopuff
and it's available in your state to
search empathy uh you can pick up a
couple or however many want of our
limited edition sparkling and Brew or
sparkling or brute and Rose and that's
what Gary was doing at Wine Library for
a little uh bottle signing for empathy
sparkling so uh first time that we've
had any wine through distribution
um it's not available on
empathywines.com
um
the rare robot is and our other core
skus R but the sparkling is just through
gopuff right now yeah hi Nate I think I
think you might have just said it but I
missed it how many states are we in now
for
um one second here I can get you the
exact number
um
so
yeah so if you are in can you John can
you hear me still yep if you are in New
Hampshire Georgia Massachusetts Maine
Missouri Ohio Virginia Michigan Alabama
Arizona California Colorado Florida Iowa
Idaho Illinois Kentucky Louisiana North
Carolina Nebraska New Jersey Oklahoma
Oregon Texas or Washington uh you can
log on to go puff right now and find our
um our sparkling wines available we
should be live in Tennessee and DC in
the next few weeks but I don't think
we're live there yet
so any of those any of those people it's
and it's most areas of the state right I
believe so yeah owns BevMo so I think
um
they do a lot of like their warehousing
in BevMo I'm not entirely certain but
um yeah most areas are those States you
should be able to go puff uh empathy
sparkling yeah from the rare robot rare
robots exclusively online on
empathywines.com but the the sparkling
is through Bill buff yeah
which like 90 of all sparkling wine in
the world is probably consumed between
now and New Year's Eve so it couldn't
have been a more intentional time for us
to release that wine but
I feel like it's one of those things
where you buy it drink it New Year's
drink it Christmas drink it over any
other holiday you're celebrating
um
but for me it's something to drink into
the spring too
I think that's what we were just talking
about earlier it's like people just
don't drink enough sparkling wine in
general
you love sparkling wine John I I do you
know that about me
um I saw someone earlier asking about
that they usually drink Bordeaux and so
if they like Bordeaux what's uh what's
the go-to wine
just saying like earlier this morning
this is this one is maybe the closest
thing that we've ever
released that would have like Bordeaux
like Tendencies I wouldn't say it's you
know gonna fool an expert in a blind
tasting but it's definitely got that
kind of like right Bank bold structure
good tannin profile to it a little
savoriness and it's mostly Merlot so
this is
um like a Merlot dominant blend
um so whoever asked that question
earlier like if you're on the fence and
you're thinking about something that's
bordeaux-like I would definitely check
out rare robot it's probably the closest
comparison that we have
end of price wise too like
Toe to Toe with Bordeaux this is gonna
pretty much blow the vast majority of
Bordeaux out of the water dollar for
dollar I think just great value
where is the production facility for
robot blend so this is a Napa Valley one
so it's sourced and
bottled and uh in Napa Valley
um in Oakville specifically
all right nobody wanted that dude I'm
here now I'm so sorry for that mess
because I'm sure that trouty and they
bored the [ __ ] out of everybody I don't
know about that I don't know YouTube all
right I'm here Carl good to see you Chef
was that teacher96 Sammy good to see you
I'm finally here I apologize
I mean I mainly apologize for the fact
that you had to deal with these two
characters uh really good to see you
Paul let's go Giovanni thank you Natalie
good to see you Carl m in the building
orenzy Tina Powell Seth Cunningham
Cassandra bright Jason Zhang thank you
so much for all of you being here uh I'm
super fired up about this I apologize
for the super late start I think a lot
of you know that I was in the store
downstairs for the last five hours
I just the thought of somebody staying
in line for three and a half hours and
then me bailing on them was just
unacceptable so we had a late start but
thank you for everybody who's been
jamming a couple things
I don't know I don't know if anybody
from the defense John trout did you see
the email that I asked to be created did
we make that email got it we got it
great
correct thank you salon so is that does
Dustin have that to throw up on here
great so team late last night I think or
this morning when did I say anything
so this morning it was yes it was
yesterday yes we had an idea so Nate I
need you to be the straight man here and
tell everybody to deal with rare robot
but I wanted to do an extra thing which
is for anybody who buys rare robot today
for them to email in the receipt in the
next 24 hours so starting right now for
next 24 hours anybody who buys a rare
robot the packages that we have what
other packages that we have named
um again three six and twelve uh three
bottles is that 60 bucks a bottle if you
buy Six it's at 55 and if you buy a case
it's at 50 bucks a bottle great so
um I'm gonna do it for 6 and 12. I
apologize to Three Bottle buyers but if
you buy Six uh bottles and send an email
or if you buy 12 will be eligible I'm
gonna give away some rare robot nfts
tomorrow
um one of each so one for the six group
one for the 12 group I'll tell you which
rare robots tomorrow but
um and so that's what's going to uh app
been at this time so if you buy six or
twelve please send the receipt to
rareobot befriends.com your receipt and
I'm going to draw one of you tomorrow
two of you one in the six group one in
12 group the 12 group will obviously get
a better rare robot nft uh the six will
also get a great one it's just an added
little kiss little fun for anybody who
decided to buy that so let's go into the
wine trout we need such little of this
wine compared to that are stunningly
High yeah we made we made like 50 cases
so a fourth of what we did with empathy
elephant yeah right so or somewhere now
we did 800 cases I think third but you
know so this is far more limited what
what can we you know again Nate John you
guys are closer to this what can we tell
people about this wine
um that's allowed to be said
um and no International right like we
like did we establish all the rules
because I know liquor laws are just
possible yeah we talked about that
already
yeah let's repeat it for the people that
have just joined yeah so uh us only I
think with empathy wines now we can ship
to about 42 States legally if you put it
in your cart and you've entered an
address and that we can ship to no
problem if you enter an address and we
can't ship to it it won't let you
purchase but so about 42 states in the
U.S right now understand
for everybody that's just the realities
of this project
um just want to give a shout out to
traveling picker
um
you know Cassandra I'm wishing you well
uh Jason cook
uh Mitchell weeks
um sending you love uh just sending
everybody a lot of positivity
um a couple things one the recession is
looming so please do not over your
extend this yourself if you can't afford
the wine do not buy the wine do not buy
the wine do not buy the wine because of
the contest for the nfts either you know
lottery tickets is not a good idea so
buy the wine you've got a real purpose
for it because you're a Wine Drinker and
you can afford it
and you want to get super premium wine
at a much better price
um
uh and that's important or number two
for a lot of people
um you know the reality is is that
they're in GIF mode
you know that I do think the Rarity of
this is pretty cool so um I think that's
important so people asking in the in the
comments where to buy the wine Let's uh
Dustin can you change the rare robot can
you go along with this dust and put
where they people can buy like and then
they're very nice and then can you add
to that dust the send send receipts to
thank you brother all right
um dad Bob wish I wasn't broke as [ __ ]
that Bob that's uh that's actually a
blessing I actually think finding
happiness without Financial
fruitfulness is actually the ultimate in
life and so I actually think that
there's a blessing in there if you
actually go deeper
um I really do
receipts are coming in very cool I
really so listen if you buy 12 like
somebody's gonna get a monster I'll just
be very transparent it's going to be a
series one rare robot which is [ __ ]
out of control the six models are going
to be a very good rare robot series too
so there is you know if you're in the
thought of like well I'm gonna buy how
much is this again
right so for the people that were gonna
buy a case of hundred dollar wine this
holiday
this is the person that should be buying
12. you were gonna buy a hundred dollar
bottle
and buy a case which is very common this
time of year because people are buying
bosses and clients gifts so I see a lot
of at Wine Library people buy a case
they need eight gifts for special people
they keep four bottles for themselves if
you're that person you should definitely
buy a case of this because you're
getting a hundred dollar quality wine
for 50 bucks plus you've got a
mathematical prayer to win tomorrow
that's definitely the person who should
consider this who should not consider
this anybody who's financially tight you
do not need 180 on three bottles of this
just cause like do not buy this for that
reason it do not over extend yourself oh
Vicky is that true final score zero zero
us England done yeah after stoppage yep
it's done zero zero
huh
and you ask
I love Vicky
um that's huge for you I'm [ __ ]
pumped
now we just have to beat the [ __ ] out of
Iran
don't cut that don't don't be that you
know please put that into context and
not just Cloud I meant in soccer
um proper football uh all right I really
want to taste this one can we like I'm
kind of sipping it without thinking
about it
what can we talk about
should we talk about how it came to be
yeah go ahead all right last year we
came out with our first be friends
collaboration it's our first non-core
emphas one
very successful
very very successful by all accounts
so we knew we wanted to do it again
we said how do we replicate a similar
style at a slightly better I apologize
skg Sunil is asking the mechanics here
are the mechanics of the giveaway if you
buy six or twelve
thus may be on the scroller you could be
send 6 and 12 bottle receipts to if you
buy six bottles or 12 bottles in the
next 24 hours so you can share this in
um the Discord
um I'm gonna do a giveaway tomorrow at
around this time 5 p.m in the Discord
for one person from each so I'm going to
probably send all the names to a
randomizing website have the team do
that click a button click a button two
people are going to win one for six one
for twelve the series one rare robot
will go to the people that order 12
bottles if you want somebody just asked
if you want to buy four cases because
you want four entries absolutely
approved if you buy 48 I'm gonna put
your name in there four times
um if you buy but they're gonna be
separate so it's not like if you buy
like if you want to do the 6 out of 12
you have to do that in separate receipts
so
um that's how we'll do that and I'm
excited about it be really fun go ahead
brother yeah
um so we want to replicate the success
that we had last year the whole idea
last year for people who didn't know
about the elephant was it was a wine
that we sold for eighty dollars a bottle
that was easily valued at two hundred
dollars plus we couldn't share what the
wine actually was and what was inside
the bottle because quite honestly we
sourced it such a such a great deal that
we couldn't disclose any of the details
and that's basically a rinse repeat of
what we did here where we
were able to Source some wine it would
cost a whole lot more
and model it under the rare robot for
between fifty and sixty dollars I mean
there's a lot of people here who've
bought the empathy elephant cab last
year like we're blown away this one is
more this is different than empathy
elephant cap just so everybody knows
this has much more terroir has much more
savoryness to it I taste beef jerky
there's soil components to it this is
more for Bordeaux and barolo and old
school Spanish wine drinkers not
California cult wine last year's wine
tasted like Caymus and special and
things of that nature and this year's
wine
is far more the rare robot wine is much
more bordeaux-like it's more Savory it's
more classic It's Not Over the Top
there's an elegance and a complexity to
this wine that I think is really
profound and so I think for people who
like Bordeaux pomerol comes to mind here
Nate for me like if somebody is like a
right Bank Bordeaux Drinker drinking
like to me when I tasted this I'm like
oh this is like a 125 Cline like that's
what that's the first thing came to mind
what did I say before Gary got your name
the right day Bordeaux John
yeah I watched a lot of Gary content I'm
impressed with your palette
I think this one more than the empathy
elephant last year too you could pop and
pour this over at Christmas and it's
ready to go
I agree somebody just asked a good
question did you just buy the fruit or
did you buy the finished wine Chris
Kelly because this is part of the
consolation family we were able to
negotiate with our partners well with
our owners they bought empathy wines but
we were able to
this is fruit that's in the system
the kind of fruit that goes into the
prisoner and all the other you know not
that this is that don't be confused the
same programs that go into other
high-end wines the schraders the
prisoners things that nature this is the
by the way it was one of the reasons we
sold empathy to Constellation their
their grape programming aka the fruit
was so much more advanced than anything
the three of us would have been able to
get to in a 20-year window that we were
able to get dramatically better wine
making and wine quality and so you know
you felt that a lot in last year's
empathy elephant I know I mean I all
year for the last 12 months I've been
getting emails from people who pop the
bottle and freaked out I think the same
thing will happen with a robot if people
are listening very carefully to what
we're saying here which is this is a
very different line it's much more
Savory it's much more balanced in my
opinion it's more drinkable now but it's
much more Bordeaux than it is Cabernet
it's actually for people who bought
empathy elephant and didn't drink at all
by the way I actually agree with this I
apologize for interrupting the little
guy deserves a chance at something Gary
hook it up I think the the three the
three Blaster three off bath or Blaster
bath you see that comment there Dustin
let's put that up there
he or she just compelled me they're
right send in your three bottle receipts
as well and I'm gonna give you something
as well all three categories that's
exactly right it's yeah it's [ __ ]
the [ __ ] am I bouging it up for six and
twelve only dust what about the little
guy and by the way it's not the little
guy it's 180 [ __ ] dollars plus
shipping real money
so three bot give big shout out to the
Blaster bath because this person
completely just brought me into the
realm Three Bottle people are in the
[ __ ] game
oh the last breath sorry I'm like
incredibly incapable of reading a big
shout out to the last breath
it's a blaster back
for finish
four and a half [ __ ] straight hours
downstairs I I can't read all right
can't [ __ ] read
uh Nate John please say something about
the wine while I gather my thoughts
wait a minute is it true people said
this it seemed like the U.S was
pressuring them more than the other way
yeah
wow now they just have to beat Iran
all right go ahead
what I was gonna say is I think for
anybody who bought the empathy elephant
they should buy this and drink them side
by side because it's a great educational
experience they're very different ones
well I think this person's right about
the Blaster bath would make a good name
for a band I was upset it also does
sound a hair inappropriate if I'm being
really transparent
so sounds like a place Nate would be
found and then go to jail
Nate what do you have to say to yourself
I could I could see myself
[Laughter]
all right we're having too much fun at
this point um
what else
yeah so again 250 cases only which is
like a quarter of the production maybe a
little bit more than what we did for
empathy elephants so
um really limited I think we're gonna
try and do things like this ongoing for
the next couple years but you know one
or two of these drops a year as long as
we can secure the quality of wine that
we want for the price
um but really I think maybe Michael
Michael C said wanted to buy but can't
ship to New Jersey but Michael yeah like
you know how easy it is to ship to
Pennsylvania or Connecticut or New York
like we're in Jersey all those places
are easy
you must know people yeah Michael you're
like a very charismatic look at you look
at your photo you're clearly a very
charismatic guy handsome you've got a
Michael please leave a comment that you
absolutely know somebody in the state of
New York Pennsylvania can we ship to all
those places Nate
uh yep great Michael put up Michael's
photo again Dustin Michael please I'm
not even gonna move on with this
um
without Michael confirming that he has
somewhere that he can ship it to even
though he lives in Jersey because that's
the beauty of New Jersey I've lived in a
lot of parts of Jersey like you know my
my main man dap my great college friend
Pete's in the room he was in that he's
in that Philly range he's down and it's
an old school Michael yeah see tap city
ship it to him please Michael please
confirm I see old photo too but I need
Michael to confirm that he has found a
place to ship it because I'm not moving
on until
um until he confirms this
right look the geek Mike is saying hit
me up but like he doesn't need you to
Michael C has friends in multiple places
all right I feel a lot better that was
like really hard on me
all right what else Nate talk to me
about the wine
let's give a little more
is there a lot more left I don't really
a good amount of merlot in this again
kind of more right Bank Bordeaux Style
there's a pop okay hold on everyone
there's a PO app for this for this video
oh that's fun
all right for all you uh web 3 nerds we
have a PO app for this live stream I
think I can see Dustin typing which
means he's probably about to give some
instructions to that that is not what's
happening sorry how do we get the poet
it
who's doing what Dustin can you pull it
yeah one second
I like this kind of getting some
like black cherry action
I get like a little like more Julio
Garcia said they haven't answered any of
us I want to make sure I'm answering
questions here that's what I've been
looking for
um
Julio get uh get your question and
oh let's go Julio's question here okay
cool probably
about the wine yeah
it's got Savory it's got like a little
like herbal like kind of like it's not
green but like it's very important like
yeah like very Bordeaux like I actually
am like surprised given that it's all
Cali juice is it
Napa yeah
this is like really well made for like
like this is like the kind of NAPA Red a
lot of people who say they they're over
Napa
like need to drink more I think it's
more old school right
I actually am really glad you guys
didn't blind taste me here because I
think this would have been like a
humbling moment I would have felt a
little rusty because I don't think I
would have pulled it
which I think is it's also different
than the um the red blend that we make
um so it's nice to have like
something that's on a different end of
the spectrum I think but from a similar
area
okay here we go do you guys sell it by
the bottle by any chance Julio we don't
it's in 3 6 and 12 packs the reason that
is is just the way the costs with
shipping like Wine's tricky like one
bottle even if you look at wine text
wine text is twenty dollars for one
bottle shipping but like
[Music]
what's up brother yeah we want shipping
one bottle of wine is really expensive
um from like a cost per bottle
standpoint model basis when you get to
three uh company people can start making
a little bit of money
um but I see a lot of people asking what
a PO app is honestly I could go through
it here but this is where Google really
comes through I'm not kidding like what
is a poapp poap Google that you'll get
such a better answer
um I think a lot of people there's a lot
of people grabbing the PO app I just saw
that teacher96 got the poapp thank you
people in the community here please uh
um teach people how to get a poapp or
what a Pro app is and then maybe some
links to a good poet
the Greek myth case of Threes is
included a case of Threes was that mean
four two three packs
or a three Three Bottle pack
a three bottle pack will get a gift a
six spot a pack of organic and 12 bottle
pack will get a gift and then for
twelves only twelves
you buy 24 36 or 48 you'll be entered
multiple times for three and six I don't
want to do all the math so three and six
is you know again if you send in four
receipts of six you'll go in four times
but only 12 will be multiplied in you
know okay I want to get this PO at yeah
so get it I'm going to dick
that was just in my mind
but it doesn't what did you uh why don't
we give everybody a little bit of what
happened in the store today Sid Dustin
Andrew sanan what did we see what was
our takeaway from what we saw today in
the four hours on the floor a lot of
thank you a lot of gratefulness dad you
want to come on video
in the building oh Sasha it's Sasha's
building
actually this building
super true
it's me
hey how's it going how's the golf going
you can have a bottle thank you let's
see what Sasha's First Take is on rare
robot red
so the OG's in the building here we go
dad what was your observations from
today's uh
today's event such a such a good wives
and good I mean
energy I wish we could do it this every
week I I I'm serious someone may come
every week
you don't have the time
but it was great everybody was so happy
and you know even the line well the line
was obviously but I saw what's going on
I mean where did everybody Park I'll be
honest with you I wouldn't [ __ ] I
don't think we'll stay in the line for
four hours four and a half hours but
that was great that's really
hmm
it's on the light side yes definitely
yeah it's not not it's not a Cabernet
correct right it's a blend it's a blend
yeah but do you sense that it's like
feels more old world
all right oh Richard parked at Walgreens
oh wow a little little gig got a parking
spot in the front
thank you
some people it reminds me of some yeah
some older style
I hate to say this even it's not the
same like barola old yeah I mentioned it
yeah I I felt like it tasted like
Bordeaux but a hint of like I mentioned
rural no I agree like I would have done
poor if this was blind I would have uh
been uh confused Vicky who's one of my
favorites says tell us a story Sasha uh
which one do you want to know mangara
brought the family to America is that
true
it's time to come to America
I was a Visionary at a young age at
three years old no dad tell her tell a
Wine Library story
they're like why well I've got something
from Gary Kim to the business
tell me you fired me well I did for for
five six hours right I think like 48.
let me let me tell that story I worked
every minute of my entire childhood and
then I asked to leave at 6 PM instead of
8 pm on a Saturday to go to one high
school party right and my dad said
you're not committed to the business
you're fired right
true story she went home
and had the best 48 Hours of my life I'm
like wait a minute this is amazing
no I cried yeah I was very upset with
you because of course
in the whole thing what did she say she
said you can't do that okay she's mom's
the chairman of the board
you fired me for asking for two hours
out of it first of all people shouldn't
be 15 years old working 12 hours days
why it's illegal
you can do anything you can start you at
five years old that's right I agree yeah
by the way you know my family you need
to work 18 hours a day
of course it's the best she's the best
I'm surprised he never gives you this
person yeah what's that what do you do
with the 24 hours I went to the party
which was awesome like you said that's
the greatest thing my dad did for me and
then the next day I didn't go to work
which was the weirdest thing and so I
hung out with AJ played video games it
was like I didn't I hadn't had a summer
vacation day in so long I didn't know
what to do with myself and then the next
day this is classic Sasha he just walks
in my room he's like coming to work I go
yeah
that was the whole that was the whole
interaction
nah it was I mean but it was it was that
was a really classic story
I also fired my daughter well she
deserved it
don't tell me what to do but that's not
by a fire she got to an argument by the
way Mike Michael yes with the red skin
whatever yeah she got an argument with
him well who knows why
I was a superstar
right I was I was a superstar right
right or wrong right right now tell them
yeah so tell them about Kenwood
Chardonnay
you know what pisses me off the most is
that I'm underrated no what pisses me
off the most when somebody said well
Gary is so successful you you your
father had the liquor store you had a
great start
[ __ ]
that's so not true
that's so natural and thrill piss me off
and I'm staying away from right because
I I would be I would be the worst if I
start writing things
responding back to some people
he's a superstar like this country never
ever had in 200 what how many years from
now guys
250 okay yeah
okay it's coming for me cheer cheers
that thank you
yeah Nate
uh Sasha never fired me as an intern as
far as I know yeah was Nate a good
internal he was the best what about
Simone you respected him a lot right yes
he slept from New York walked yeah
walked yes you really respected me I had
a lot of respect for for uh
both of you guys by the way what about
trout oh trout
not really it was around a lot though he
worked at the main select but he was
around a lot yeah oh yeah that's right
he worked uh
the best story when we're worth become
oh don't tell that story don't tell that
story
I'm taking the fifth I'm not that one
all right we gotta get back on track
here now what's going on with them
what's going on is it people buy 3 6 and
12 and send in receipts they're gonna
get a v friends nft raffle that's a big
[ __ ] deal
the other thing is it's sixty dollars
fifty five dollars and fifty dollars
depending on how many bottles you buy
in terms of what you meant by if you buy
12
multiple times if you buy 12 if you buy
12 if you buy 24 if you buy 36 because
people somebody asked what if I bought
you know uh three or four cases
if you buy cases you're entered multiple
times so if you buy 24 bottles or 36
bottles you'll be in the raffle two
times three times whereas if you buy
three and six that's only just just do
that once so there's that's the that's
the clarity on that there's a PO app
um let's see what's going on I want to
ask a question hold on Dustin Dustin
yeah 24 hours so I don't know oh did you
hear what happened did we win zero zero
oh [ __ ] no that's good yeah it's good
no but I mean and it sounded like the
U.S had more opportunities than England
right right
once it's went to they hit the post
right yeah or crossbar crossbar
that's a surprise this morning I was
talking to somebody we're going to
probably lose one nothing put nothing to
one something like that and you know
what that's a huge thing it's such a
huge Tuesdays
with Iran we need to visit the ship
that's what I said the same exact thing
it's the same exactly DNA DNA you get it
for me
all right get out of here you're still
in the show I need trout we gotta I need
I need to blow it yes you can have them
[Laughter]
all right good for you all right it's a
great result for the U.S South Dakota
um
so when I said the wine is sweet the
smoke the wine is not sweet the wine is
dry bone dry actually very dry and the
fruit is very balanced and so um I think
it's a it's really well made
I I have one a question yeah you're
going to have multiple characters on the
labels down the road as you know this is
the third collaboration we've done with
empathy empathy elephant the meerkat
Muscat
right and now this is the third one rare
robot no they're out Nate and John are
gone from constellation
of course for my Personal Collection
look at this yeah
Mensch he's a good boy you know what it
meant yeah what about Sid dad
yeah what about little Lou I oh
blah blah blah what about old Lou
oh a little bit of Rocky whatever but a
rocky decade you love them for a little
while then it was a rocky decade but
now you're back
all right I gotta read some stuff you
really need to sort out the shipping in
the UK you know what gas Ferry the
problem is we've got such an incredible
relationship with consolation
the international shipping with alcohol
is just incredibly challenging
um I will say this this is some Alpha
um I've got multiple trips already
locked in traveling abroad next year and
we'll be doing a lot of v-friends events
around those trips uh so I'll be in the
Middle East in March I'll be in Dubai
I'm going to do a meet up there details
to come
um our UK offices exploding so I'll be
in London quite a bit that will happen
we have an office in Amsterdam now I'll
be there as well we're working on one in
Germany we'll be there I have a major
trip to Asia so I'll be doing a meet up
in Singapore potentially in Malaysia and
Indonesia so I'm gonna be making my
first trip to Japan ever it's one of the
few places I've never been you want to
come okay so a lot of a lot of travel
next year that is going to lead to a lot
of meetups and I also as some of you saw
the other day we're working on a very
interesting live streaming platform for
you friends so a lot of exclusive live
streams if you own the nft with very
remarkable people from Shaquille O'Neal
to Sasha vaynerchuk
all right what else in here
look are you out of here are you going
home
okay
good goodbye bye are you playing or
what's going on yeah he wants to know
how your golf games going Nate yeah the
golf game's solid the winter always you
know is a drag me tell Dad that you know
AJ's obviously got his golf came much
stronger but tell them what you see in
my natural Talent even though I've only
played like 10 times
uh Gary played a full round at 18 holes
and I was very impressed by both his
swing and his score
he's a multi-talented kid
he's got the town he's got the talent
for it I don't know yeah tell everybody
when I when we what about what about
Chappelle what about his draw on the at
Christmas I mean that's unbelievable
I've been talking to my wife at 47 and
nine months we've been married I said we
have to do a DNA test because I'm not so
sure it's my son and she said you know
what some days I wonder if it's myself
I'm there I'm absolutely I'm the best of
both my parents it's actually true I
literally took the best of their
attributes because their shortcomings
are pretty profound and luckily I didn't
get any of them
no listen right I have shortcomings too
yeah okay all right I love you guys
great to see you have a great holidays
happy holidays okay what's going on here
Jennifer great to see you proven great
to see you uh Adrian thank you so much
um uh
questionnaire what about Book Games book
games is played forever
um we've got some book game stuff
brewing for the first time in a little
while I want to remind everybody that
was only a couple months ago that we did
stuff six months ago with book games so
there's more on the horizon yes
for the person who's not minted in Book
Games December 31st and they go into a
kitty the wheel control I am coming uh
Akash I'm going to Toronto as well
multiple times next year we're opening
an office of vaynermedia office in
Toronto right vaynermedia is exploding
so we're just kind of like doing a lot
we have India now work you know just a
lot of good stuff going on book games
this forever the PO app is expiring
at 4 25 PM which is what time is it now
five minutes is there a link to get to
the bow app just the secret word that
you just entered so go to the poapp app
somebody can link that and there's a
secret word and what's a secret word
rare robot 1155 rare robot 1155.
understood all right that's the poab
stuff now uh I'm from Toronto will there
be an opening party maybe Barry we'll
definitely uh I'm a Zach Wilson guy I
think it's still early in the equation
but I like Mike White I like every jet
you know so that's that
um any final thoughts as we wrap up here
sorry everybody that's done it's 4 20
now
right it was supposed to be three to
four I was late so we'll hang for a few
more minutes
only OG's will recognize trouty Sid and
Dustin today at the store he made a
point that me it was so nice to say
hello to him question a trouty Gary
favorite cheese to pair with rare robot
to me this is
I think like a soft truffle cheese would
work for me on this some Murphy
like uh hard cheeses parmesan maybe
something like that
I like your pick better but I had to go
somewhere Nate any part parting thoughts
um
just want everyone to have a nice happy
holidays
you know
enjoy some time friends and family good
wine good food oh tell them about the
Macy's yeah for anybody who watched the
Macy's Parade yesterday you probably saw
them driving everyone oh my God Nate
look hold on it's cute
Nate tell this story
tell this story I'm in a meeting I wish
I could find the photo right now this
was like five six years ago Gary much
later later eight eight nine eight years
ago EJ was still working on Vayner uh
Gary sends me and AJ a photo from a
meeting he was in it was like the guy
meeting in somebody's office like this I
see a photo of a human being in a frame
it's like a person's cousin or brother
or something
me I take a photo of it
I'm gonna try and find it
it is a photo oh man on Earth it
literally looks like like
me and AJ
message had a baby in the basement baby
and this human came out it is so
profound they keep looking
it is so wild
it is so wild
it looks exactly like that I feel like
you pulled it from the archives not that
long ago
I'll find it
there we go I got it
it's exciting three this excites me too
this is a photo zoom in Yep this is H
ussain scroll go closer to the screen
extremely yeah there you go this I see
this photo and I'm like oh my God this
is if Nate and AJ had a child
right do you see it guys it is crazy
crazy
yeah that was that was funny
how do we deal with the rising cost of
shipping and Logistics and e-commerce
business you've all got to pass on the
costs this is what inflation is
you either need to make more margin on
your core product or you pass on the
costs to the consumer and I mean we
locked
injury asks why is it so hard to ship to
Toronto because Canadian law go ahead
Nate
um shouty and I are no longer full-time
at constellation but also locking in
contracts with 3pl's
um and you know as the good thing about
constellation too is we could negotiate
have a lot more purchasing power tell
everybody what you guys are both up to
now that you were no longer a
consolation with the empathy deal yeah
so where trouty and I are both no longer
full-time at constellation however we're
still uh working on our baby empathy
wines and obviously in an ongoing
capacity so that's going nowhere
um but it's unreal robot Brett go ahead
um I don't know if people saw Gary's uh
birthday a couple weeks ago
um but we or Gary
um did a lot of individual kind of
Charity through GoFundMe and then going
forward I'll be working with Gary on a
private Foundation where we're hoping to
help individuals and families that need
it the most
can you
uh I'm working with the V Friends team
right so Nate
so let me get this right John you're
trying to help me to create money and
then Nate is giving away all my money
that's right so who's that it's just a
circle you know right right so child's
working hard to try to generate it and
I'm working hard to try and okay
it's a really good way of putting it
actually I like that I wouldn't I
wouldn't say giving it away I'd say
that's exactly what I'm doing I'm giving
away my money it's a you know there's
there's other ways to spin it how would
you spin it uh
helping people with the money that
trouty generates for you
I love it anyway I'm excited about the
private Foundation I'm going to be doing
a lot more it's going to need obviously
family we've been together a long time I
needed somebody to come in who really
knows me and so I think we're going to
be able to do a lot of positive impact
on the world and then and then very
seriously because I think about the
selfish and selfless part of my world
it's really cool that Nate and John are
working at like I think be friends will
be the business that creates my
opportunity buying the New York Jets I
think will be my professional Legacy
be friends is especially exciting
because it's selfish and selfless
because it's a business but I do think
as we build accountable and and as we
build an ambitious Angel as we build all
these characters I think we have a
profound impact on the world I've been
spending a lot of time on Sesame Street
lately I think a lot about what Sesame
Street meets Pokemon means that's how I
think a lot about with B Brands Marvel
Disney so I'm really excited about it
Bob I grew back in the driver's seat of
Disney
some interesting stuff
um anyway we're gonna be heading out
and I agree
[Music]
[Music]
a machine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I desire to care
[Music]
[Music]
um all right final recap
[Music]
final recap wait a minute show me Han's
question for Jeremy's question is
Jeremy can you re-ask it I don't see oh
why evolving pose on this bottle ah very
good question Jeremy look I think I've
been alluding to evolving posts I've
been seeing a lot of you big shout out
yeah I haven't really talked like this
because I don't want to create
speculation but I have noticed several
of you on this
um on this live stream have been very
clever in picking up evolving poses in
series two on the open market during
this winter
and I think it's because
I have very specific thoughts about what
we're doing with evolving poses poses
and scenes in series two will continue
to play out like I've said
but the evolving pose is the one to me
I'm very fascinated by people
who got that because it was remember it
was a free surprise series one holders
got that for free
it's a very important one for me it's
very important for the people that have
the series one and the evolving together
that's a little Alpha but a valve
imposes matter to me and so I wanted
both looks on the bottle
um and so
yeah I don't want to give too much I
continue to not want to create
speculation but
I appreciate all of you happy holidays
thank you for being here we love you
we'll talk to you soon thank you John
and Nate
um one last time to buy the
winesgaryvee.com rare robot if you buy
three six or twelve bottles please send
the receipt into rareobot befriends.com
people that buy 12 bottles uh will be
entered to get a series one rare robot
three and six will be series two this
will end tomorrow at 4 P.M Eastern so
all orders before then and submitted and
then somewhere between five and midnight
tomorrow we will give away those three
nfts
um I love all of you thank you for being
part of this community we're very
thrilled thank you for everybody who's
picked up some uh the wine is
spectacular you know if you're really a
serious Red Wine Drinker I highly
recommend especially if you like
barolo and Bordeaux this is that style
balanced medium body
um and uh and thank you John Anita love
you guys thank you for the rest of the
team thank you for all of you guys I
know it's a holiday weekend the whole
crew here that's been with me at the
store thank you for all of you that came
to the store today it was just love
lovely to spread love and positivity and
we'll see you guys all soon thanks guys
and gals see ya hustling hamster Alpha
you know